so hello everybody i am here with father
andrew dominic and father steven de
young
both of them are working with ancient
faith radio and
started a new podcast called the lord of
spirits and
the people around me the people that
watch my videos everybody has been
really excited about this podcast i
listened to the first episode
and it's very very fascinating it's a
very it's an exploration
of the world of angels of spirits of
demons
basically trying to help people
understand that uh
as christians as believers we don't
believe that it's just
us and god although we do believe that
god the god we worship is transcendent
is beyond time beyond space beyond
everything it's uncreated
but that between us and god let's say in
the hierarchy of beings there's a whole
bunch of stuff
going on that's how the ancients
understood it that's how the fathers
understood it
and so they are trying to dive back into
that understanding and present it to us
today in a manner
that we can understand and that can also
help us
transform our lives in relation to all
of this now i'm gonna have some
questions some tough questions too i
hope they're ready uh in terms of
what this means and what the
consequences of going into this might be
because i've as you've seen in my videos
i've been
uh tempted by talking about this more
and more and so
uh yeah so i think we're gonna have a
lot of fun
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so i don't know who is going to speak
first but i would like you to maybe
uh tell us a little bit about your
vision for this podcast
you know what you're trying to
accomplish and then we'll just dive in i
think we'll we'll probably have to cut
it short because there's so many things
we could probably talk about and so
we'll see
yeah um well i'll i'll go first i
i usually go first on the actual show
because i'm the one who's looking at all
the blinky lights
uh so uh in the studio
but yeah so you know father stephen and
i have come bring very different things
to the table
and my desire to do this show
was number one in some ways to
um to give a wider audience to some of
the work that father stephen has been
doing in terms of talking about
the the bible especially and in the
orthodox tradition in its
full sense and especially in the sense
that is
maybe hidden from us as people who tend
to function as materialists
right and so uh the reason why i've been
fascinated by that stuff is
because you know serving for a number of
years as a pastor and still doing
pastoral work in another different kind
of way now um
i think one of the biggest problems that
we have in our age is that we tend to
function as materialists we tend to
function even if we're believing
christians
we tend to function in a way that
suggests
that the 3d world is all that there is
and occasionally we maybe add in some
god here and there
and then you know if we're then we
occasionally maybe add in some saints
and angels if
we feel like really desperate you know
god please do this for me and oh by the
way you saints and angels please help
you know and the the truth is that's a
very anemic
way of understanding the spiritual life
and uh so i'm also fascinated by
narrative
and um i think narrative is really the
way that we understand and organize
reality the way that we actually able to
approach it
and so much of what we're talking about
in this program
is about uh reclaiming narratives that
are in orthodox tradition they're in the
scriptures they're in the church fathers
they're in the liturgical services
but have become opaque to us because of
our modern culture and and it's you know
secular humanistic materialism so that's
kind of the nutshell
of what it is that i what i'm interested
in particularly for this
for this particular program father
stephen maybe tell us
about your research and uh you know the
way you've been presenting it to people
i know in the blog for a while
but now in this uh in this podcast tell
us a bit about the angle and what you're
trying to accomplish with what you're
doing
yeah i'm i'm the uh bible nerd of uh
of our duo um i actually went and got a
phd in it and
and uh i've spent a lot of my life
studying ancient dead languages
um but um i i think a big part
of uh what has motivated me
is i don't think
that as as orthodox christians living in
the west for the most part we sort of
fully appropriated
our tradition it's all there it's all in
the tradition it's in our liturgics it's
it's in the fathers
it's in the scriptures themselves but
we've
tended to in part i think because we're
doing this work in english
so we start out adopting traditional
english language theological terms
sort of our interpretive grid for
theology and understanding god and
understanding the scriptures has been
dictated by
sort of modern assumptions mostly modern
protestant assumptions especially in
terms of the bible and so
uh you know we try to figure out what's
the orthodox view
of justification what's the orthodox
view
of predestination we take these western
categories and just try to plug in the
orthodox
stance you you don't end up with the
orthodox faith that way you end up with
sort of a an orthodox-ish
form of western western christianity
and so i've been trying mainly to try to
to pull out some of this stuff that's
there
in the scriptures uh there in our
our tradition especially very early
fathers there
in the jewish traditions of the second
temple period that form the background
for the new testament
that people just don't know about and
sort of show that hey
this is what's there that there's a
whole other way
of understanding all of these things
that's more original
that is the basis of the orthodox faith
and that we're just unaware of that's
already with one episode
in the bag the most common comment we
get
either from a critical side or a
non-critical side is why haven't i heard
this before
well one of the things that we've been
that has been a disservice to us
let's say in the west is our
translations have been
a a desire to de-mythologize the the
scripture
and so you know when i i tell people
that you know in
the creation narrative it says that god
created sea monsters and people
they've never seen it but it's right
there in front of you they just use
words to kind of make you think that to
to make to avoid the problems or to
avoid all the strange characters the
dragons the demons the
the strange you know gods that are named
or these these strange mythological
creatures
they don't they there has been this
attempt to kind of
shield this from us in order to protect
christianity in the modern world
but now in the the past few decades what
we've had is we've had
kind of secular atheist type biblical
scholars
come at us with arrows and knives and
say all of this stuff is there and
tried to bring it back and christians
have no idea and so one of the things
i'm excited about what you're doing
is saying we're going to do this but
we're going to do it in a way to show
that it's completely coherent with
our christian tradition it's not an
opposition to it it doesn't
it's not there to undermine what we
would we believe
yeah yeah we don't have to be
embarrassed by the appearance of
monsters and spirits and so forth in the
bible
you know they are there
there's a there's this idea that we need
to sort of make
christianity respectable right we need
to we need to make sure that it's
something we can talk about
in polite company at cocktail parties
with educated people
you know and so if we start talking
about demons or we start talking about
sea monsters or we start talking about
giants they're going to laugh at us so
we need to
figure out some some way to paper over
that
you know some other way to to understand
that so that we can all be
you know modern intellectual respectable
folk
yeah yeah um and so i would
my big question this is like i'm gonna
go straight to the toughest question i
i would say is one of the reasons that i
have been
very going very slowly at this or kind
of bringing people slowly onto this
point of view which is
this notion of these principalities of
these these
beings is i'm afraid of the marvel
comics
spirituality like i'm afraid of the
marvel comics version of mythology which
is
that everything is on the same level
right so
you have these beings but they're all
basically
like us right they're all basically on a
kind of material
sphere i would say uh and so it you know
thor's on another planet and these gods
are kind of floating in space or
you know the recent version we've heard
are things like they're in other
dimensions
this type of speaking which is trying to
use scientific speak
to explain these beings um
but always trying to explain them on the
on the same level
and so this is the thing that i'm a
little worried about because what
to me what it ends up creating is a kind
of science fiction version of the
the bible and so i don't know if that's
something you've thought about yeah like
one thing you notice for instance in the
recent marvel
films i think the last i think was the
last avengers movie
you know thor gets a beer belly
right so like i mean this is this is
this is the the reification of
of thor you know that he's he's real
he's so real he can get
you know become a deadbeat and get drunk
and have a beer belly right
and and be out of shape um
whereas no one who ever worshipped thor
and the christians who encountered thor
worshipers
would have ever seen him that way they
would have regarded you know
those who worshipped him would have
regarded him as a god and those who
encountered those worshipers were
regarded as a demon
which are both biblical terms for the
same kinds of beings
and he you know he was not just a human
with kind of superpowers who lives on
another planet
but but but actually this this spiritual
being who
through uh sacrifices and through sin
frankly is in communion with this group
of people and affecting them and there
they've made him part of their community
and he's
you know super dangerous right he's you
know so
that the powers that he wields are virtu
by virtue of his with the kind of being
that he
is and and he's not he's not just like
us like
he doesn't get bummed out like us he
doesn't uh you know fall in love like us
he doesn't
get a beer belly like us that's just not
what thor
is just as an example you know but but
yeah
it's i mean i've i've long loved comic
books and father stevens
is a comic uh comic book lover as well
uh
but uh you know that's not that's not
the real thor
yeah well there are analogies let's say
i mean i like comic books too
for sure and i i think that there are
analogies to help us
understand sometimes you can use
analogies of physical power to help you
understand spiritual power there are
there are ways to use those tropes and
let's say the manner in which even in
the stories of the gods that they're
told they're told that way
right the the gods are are tol are
described in ways that have
massive uh let's say physical power and
that they they manifest this power
there's a there's a mapping on of the of
the two worlds let's say there's a
mapping on of the higher world
with the lower world and we use words
from the lower world to talk about it
but but angels don't right angels don't
have
physical bodies or they have something
like subtle bodies or
you could call them that i don't know am
i wrong in my understanding
father stephen what is your vision of
this well i
i think uh to begin with your original
question i think
really getting into the reality of this
does the exact opposite
um i think the whole spiritual world and
god himself has been sort of
domesticated
by sort of modern theology especially
protestant theology um you know you
you've got calvinism which basically has
a god who's
within time and sometime in the ancient
past sat down and wrote out everything
that was going to happen
yeah you know and if he didn't do that
then he's not sovereign and he's not in
control
right you know or and then you have you
have people who respond to that and go
the other way with open theism who say
that god
like doesn't know the future right so
we've we've got these words that are so
humanized god so i think when we come
and say
well no if you look at the scriptures
you know the alien or the angels are
these
vast cosmic intelligences
you know that that help
god in his governing of the spiritual
and
the material world you know i think
that's a much
less sort of marvelous you know that's
less
justice league yeah no and i think the
word intelligence is probably the
i mean it's a traditional word to talk
about these beings and it's probably
a good way to speak about them in a
manner that people can maybe understand
what we're dealing with here
um because one of the things you said
i think was it was in the first episode
or maybe i read it on on your blog where
you talk about the notion that
that the spiritual world and for the
ancients even though it's seen as these
intelligences that are that are above us
and that are kind of managing the world
they nonetheless map on to the physical
world right there's a
there's a correlation and so you have
places in the world that are like
you know the gates of hell or the the
mountain of the gods or you have all
these physical spaces in the world that
kind of [ __ ] that say concentrate these
spiritual
powers but it doesn't it doesn't mean
that
let's say that if you went up the mount
olympus you would find god
you'd find zeus sitting there kind of
you know fiddling away at his
at his uh lightning bolts you know uh
but it's difficult because people are so
materialistic that i i'm
always afraid sometimes that
like you understand what i'm talking
about because sometimes i'm a little
worried when i talk to people about this
stuff
we have the the ancients saw these
things as sort of overlapping
like to use a modern term it's like you
have a transparency over a photo
you know and so the atrousian lake for
example
was a lake in hades in sheol in the
underworld
and it was the place of for for plato it
was the place of forgetting where the
souls
sort of lose their memories before they
get reincarnated
uh in in general greco-roman paganism it
was just forgetting their former lives
completely and sort of starting to
dwindle away to nothingness
christians adopt that and in a lot of
the early
christian apocryphal works like the life
of adam and eve
they have repentant people in hades at
the coming of christ being baptized in
that leg
and being cleansed of their sins and
then able to enter into
into paradise um but that lake
you know we could talk about how that
functions in the stories of these
but that was also a lake in italy
you could go there yeah that's it's an
actual physical lake
and they didn't think it represented
this spiritual reality
they thought those two things were the
same they overlapped
it's more like a man i always use the
word manifesting in the sense that it's
not
an arbitrary representation but it's a
condensation of something
which is beyond what it's condensating
like it it
it actually it's actually manifesting
this principle but
the print the principle or the
intelligent part of it is
beyond what is being shown to you let's
say you know just like a church really
does
it really the physical building of the
church really does become
the place where christ descends you know
manifest themselves in the cup really
really
you know but but you cannot limit that
just to the blood and bread that's in
the
in the cup because it there's something
else going on there's a there's
it's pointing us bringing us into
something higher than what's there yeah
and and also that
that human participation makes a big
difference in terms of what people
actually experience
right so like early on uh one of the
the uh the memes that i think father
stephen shared on our podcast facebook
page
had these two pictures on it and on the
top you see this very plain
very primitive looking sort of village
with huts
you know and uh and then on the bottom
you see this
uh idyllic countryside where you see
mythological beings cavorting with human
beings
and they're labeled separately i'm i'm
doing this from memory so i forgive
getting
wrong but the top one with the sort of
primitive
bare you know set of huts it says
something like
what a video camera would have seen and
then at the bottom it says what ancient
people has experienced
yeah and so you know what is the
difference between those two
like if i go to those huts i'm probably
going to just see huts
because i don't i don't know how to
participate in the same way that those
people did
right and so you know and and and i
think that that's that's
that's one of the key things right is
this sense of ritual participation but
also just having a
having the the imagination and and by
that i don't mean that they're
coming up with ideas in their heads and
then they they're seeing things
but i'm seeing i'm saying having the
ability to
recognize something as being there and
and having that ability then you
actually do see more right
so so you know like for instance you
talked about that lake in italy
just because you go to that place in
italy and stick your toe in doesn't
necessarily mean you're
gonna forget everything you ever knew
right there there's there's something
else going on there at the same time
right
there's certain conditions that kind of
have to be met in order to have that
specific experience
uh you know and and like i'm still kind
of grappling to get a handle on a lot of
this stuff
father stephen's been working with it
for a lot longer but what one of the
things that i've found that's really
fascinating to me is that
so much of it is i have this internal
feeling of like i've always wanted this
to be real
i always wanted this to be true and now
actually now i have a coherent way of
understanding how it is in fact
true right so these sort of human
intuitions that we have about
the presence of spirits for instance
uh there is a vocabulary there is a
tradition to understand and access
and approach in the right way these
realities because
like there are other ways to access them
that are not the right way
you know you can engage in the occult
you can engage in like we were talking
about offline psychedelic drug usage you
can engage in this stuff
and get in contact with the spiritual
world but uh
you're lost that's the the difficulty is
that a lot of the
there's a hierarchy of beings and
there's also a hierarchy in the good
sense in the sense that you know
that which is connected to which is
above but there's also a hierarchy in
the sense that there's a bunch of stuff
that's disconnected or
that's wild and not that you know that
is
beings that are on their own and doing
their own thing and
people have no way of discerning how
what or how what they're encountering
when they
they they go on these trips at least
that's my perception you know people
i remember one time a guy who i respect
very much
but he was telling me about psychedelics
and he was you know he was trying to get
me to do psychedelics a lot of people
are trying to get me to do psychedelics
um and and so i was asking questions and
i'm like okay well tell me about your
thing you know explain it to me and he's
saying and then he says well she you
take psychedelic
and if you ever see a monster he said
you know just relax just relax
and like ask it what it has to teach you
and i'm like
you know what let's let's move on to
something else because
if i see a monster i'm not going to ask
it what it has to teach me
because that would probably not be good
for my soul you know
it's it's funny and i want to yeah right
don't talk to the monsters
but you know it's funny like so within
24 hours of our first episode
we must have received i don't know five
or six messages
from people that essentially kind of
went like this
my house is haunted what am i supposed
to do about this
you know and and i mean like we're gonna
we're gonna talk about this at some
point but yeah i mean
father stephen you could probably
comment on that like like i don't know
it's so funny we're just kind of
there's this explosion of interest that
we've experienced
and so there's an unending list of
topics you know
well yeah and and there's you know i
frequently brought up when i'm talking
about this and you've heard me do it
like it's speaking engagements i bring
up the fact that for example saint john
chrysostom in one of his homilies
instructs his people on what to do when
they encounter the spirit of a dead
loved one
so apparently this happened frequently
enough to people
that he had to give them directions on
what they should do
right and and how they should handle it
and what did he say i need to know what
did he say
he said assume it's a demon right until
prove it otherwise
assume it's a demon trying to trick you
but i say that and people kind of
chuckle and they're like wow that's
weird
but then when everyone else leaves the
room
i have people start coming up to me and
say hey
when my mom died when my dad died when
my aunt died when my grandma died
i kind of did they tell me they've had
that experience
and i think these experiences
are well because this is reality
because spiritual reality is reality
people have these experiences
they try to write them off or re-explain
them or
man i must have something weird or you
know or
uh or whatever or they just don't admit
that they've had them because everybody
again they won't be respectable
everybody will look at them like they're
crazy
you know so so uh
this reality intrudes on people's lives
and so part of what i think is valuable
about what we're trying to do
hopefully for people is that we'll give
them a content an orthodox context in
which to
talk about and and understand that you
know and and what
what do you do with your houses on well
i've done an exorcism on a house
and i ended up doing it because it
wasn't an orthodox person it was a
person from a nazarene church
but he went to his pastor and said hey
this weird stuff is happening this thing
grabbed me and left
like burnt finger marks on my body
what do i do and this nazarene pastor
was like i don't know you need to go
find a priest
you need to go fast don't you watch
movies find a priest what do you do here
i got this is it in my wheelhouse right
this i don't have the toolbox for this
right so i mean these things happen to
people and
and they're normal in the sense that
they're part of
the whole world we've just done
everything we can to blind ourselves
to the whole spiritual element of the
world around us yeah
well one of the things that's being
opened up i would say right now
is there are certain scientists and
certain thinkers
um there's someone his name is don
hoffman who's kind of
attracting a lot of attention um and
he's
he's positing that consciousness is
basically
a fundamental part of of the world like
it's a fundamental particle
of of the universe and that it scales
down
the human it scales down from our
experience all the way down to the
sub-atomic level
and it scales up as well beyond
persons and then this phenomena of
consciousness scales
up and and so you know and he's really
kind of
muddling around you can tell that he
doesn't have any traditional metaphysic
he
hasn't studied philosophy he's really
doing it as a scientist but he's
he's trying to account for consciousness
which is the last thing
that scientists are unable to really
account for they can't explain it they
don't understand it
despite the fact that it's through
consciousness that they're saying
everything they're saying that they're
everything they're doing is basically
through the the lens of consciousness
but they can't account
for that phenomena they think it's just
a phenomena it's not a phenomena right
it's a
it's it's the place the place meeting of
heaven and earth we could say
um but what happens is that it opens up
the possibility even for
materialists or kind of scientifically
minded the possibility that
the world actually organizes itself not
just in material categories but
in consciousnesses you know and if you
join that with a
kind of traditional metaphysics if you
imagine let's say the platonic
metaphysics of ideas
that the notion that there's a hierarchy
of concepts you could say or ideas
whereas the real traditional way of
understanding it is that no there's a
hierarchy of beings
the world manifests itself through
beings and that
even things in the world that say
sectors of reality
are have principalities that are beings
that are managing those
those things and it's hard for people to
kind of grasp that
but if you in our human endeavor that's
how it works right we have
a mayor we have a president we have a
general we have these characters that
are acting as principalities
on on larger constituents you could say
yeah i'm i'm totally fascinated by pan
psychism
which is what you're talking about yeah
yeah um
in large part because it accords with
uh you mentioned you know the platonic
metaphysics but
i mean back when i was studying
philosophy
i was i did a thesis on in aristotle's
physics
aristotle has everything having a will
anything that has a nature has a will
because will is a function of nature
which is also part of our orthodox
theology that separates us from the west
in a lot of ways
but that's sort of treated as some kind
of weird crude
of course by modern people reading
aristotle they're like oh this is some
weird crude
he's you know humanizing natural
elements and the world soul and all of
this but
but this was basic to the ancient view
is that there are these consciousnesses
associated with everything
in the material world and
uh as you say that the idea that they
scale based on the complexity of the
system
that they represent but uh and then
the question was like when you read
philo
responding to plato in a jewish context
he's saying
these consciousnesses aren't gods to be
worshipped in their own right
right they're gods we would put it with
a small g
but they're they're those beings created
by and appointed by
the god to to administer his creation
and through whom he administers
administers his creation and then the
the idea of
demonic rebellion is that some of these
powers have rebelled
and were being worshipped as gods by
by the various nations treated as ends
in themselves
rather than as as part of this hierarchy
that leads toward
the god yeah that's
it's one of the questions is probably
this is a question that i've had for a
very very long time so i'm going to ask
father stephen because
i want an answer to this so one of the
things that i
i would say people are going to call me
a heretic now but one of the things that
i've appreciated
let's say in in the islamic uh
cosmology is the possibility of the
jinns okay
that is it seems to me this is and i
might be wrong because maybe i i do come
from a protestant background but it
seems to me that
in the christian cosmology of which i'm
aware of there's this idea that there
are let's say
angelic beings that are connected in the
hierarchy to god
and then there are demonic beings that
are rebelling and therefore
let's say fallen or or
are scattered full of pride and and
pulling people pulling the world apart
let's say
diabolos um but we don't seem to have
the possibility of
beings that are neutral or that are
ambiguous
in between and we don't have that but
then they reappear
nonetheless as like fairies and gnomes
and all these
all these uh let's say kind of folk
beings that are there for the christians
even though they're not part of their
official
chrisman christian cosmology let's say
so to me that's like something that i've
always wondered about
are there traces in the fathers or in in
let's say
in the traditional text or the extra
biblical
extra biblical uh stories where we talk
there there is this idea of neutral or
ambiguous beings
yeah i i think um i think there are two
answers to that first is that um that's
sort of where humans are
because humans are humans are both
immaterial and material
right but by being a soul-body unity
humans are the bridge
between the unseen and the seen world
and so we are sort of
in in between in that regard or able to
move in either direction
would probably be would probably be a
better description
the other place where you see that kind
of thing is is
with the idea of the giants
where you have this kind of um and we
could talk about how to see that but
this quote-unquote hybridization
idea of something fallen and something
human
right and and there are
um there are some outlier traditions but
there
are some outlier traditions that have
uh people who would be categorized as
giants
but who are nonetheless righteous or
repentant and i think father andrew's
favorite one
that i that i pointed out to him is that
there is actually a tradition
that noah had
some kind of nephilim connection himself
yeah and then they
represented different ways like with his
children or
he himself is kind of a because he's an
artisan even in the regular story
he you can see that he has something of
cain's descendants because
he builds a boat and that all is in in
kane's lineage
yeah and there are a lot of stories of
his miraculous birth and there are a
whole series of stories where after his
sort of miraculous weird birth
his father lamech is kind of like hey is
this mine
you know like or
did what did like an angelic being get
involved here because he seems to be
right he has to sort of be reassured and
the dynamics of a lot of those stories
actually get they get inverted but they
get reused
by saint matthew in his gospel in terms
of
saint joseph's questioning when the
theotokos
becomes with child now they get inverted
because he's told the opposite answer
lamik's sort of reassured
like no it's he's your child then just
like nope it's not
whereas joseph it's like yeah no it's
not you know humans
but uh it's the the same kind of
dynamics in this in the story get played
out so there is
that those would be the two places i
think where you would see something like
that
even then i don't think there's ever
really neutrality
but there's the capability for certain
beings to move in either direction
they're not sort of locked in in place
yeah
because c.s lewis seems to want to try
to
cast that idea and so you know he takes
the
the different kind of uh little gods or
the like the
the woodland creatures and the woodland
spirits and he recast them
in his narnia series as
being somehow something which i think
are akin to the gin like are these
these these these characters that you
don't really know like they're kind of
neutral they're
you're not sure some of them are with
asl and some of them aren't and some of
them can flip
um anyway so i just thought i just was
wondering about that because i see that
someone like jesus seems to have tried
to to create something akin to that in
his
in his series yeah and and you know i
mean so
you know you know you and i have talked
about tolkien in the past a little bit
and tolkien tries to deal with this on
some level too
right so on the one hand you know we
were talking earlier about the idea of
spiritual beings were engaged at kind of
every level of creation kind of helping
to make it go
like one of the best fictional
depictions of that is
in the silmarillion by j.r tolkien when
when you have
the one god who creates this you know
the angelic beings and they're engaged
in all this and so forth
and then and then some of them rebel
right
uh justice happened in the real the real
world
um and at the same time then there's
various kinds of creatures that exist in
his world like
like uh you know that that seem to
not necessarily always be entirely
aligned in one direction or another
although if you really had to sort them
out i think you could probably do it
but like the one of the ways that he
attempts to kind of solve this problem
is you have men and elves but he
essentially says that elves are
essentially a kind of
version of man you know that they're two
different
types of peoples of the same one species
yeah right like a cat like a caste
system of some kind
sort of yeah sort of um but but of
course you know elves can be evil too
even though like when you encounter them
in the lord of the rings they're
generally
you know almost divinized right um
but but yeah so so it's interesting how
how there's various people that are
attempting to kind of
work out how to deal with these problems
of
you know the the how do you represent
spiritual forces in the world and also
what do you do with the fact that
mankind has always kind of seen
up until relatively recently has kind of
seen fairies and sprites and gnomes
around every tree i think one of the
problems that makes it difficult for us
to understand that
is that especially since the victorian
era
a lot of those creatures have been have
been kind of domesticated
so like tolkien hated for instance one
of the things he hated about shakespeare
now he's pre-victorian
but one of the things he had about
shakespeare is that shakespeare's
fairies
are kind of too small they're they're
too
weak right they're too cute uh and and
that really becomes extreme in the
victorian
peter pan yeah yeah right and and now
you get you know
images of you get tinkerbell tinkerbell
is the ultimate in cute fairies
although it's interesting how tinkerbell
is then presented in pure pan as being
ultimately dangerous
right tinker bell attempts to kill wendy
you know
so so even then you saw this idea that
they're dangerous
but but but they've been made much much
smaller right
uh whereas um tolkien's elves and and
fairies and so forth are a dangerous
people to run into and generally not a
good idea
so one of one of the things that i i
don't bring up often but i think in this
case it's it's probably a good idea to
bring up
the the author uh renegade who was like
an early century traditionalist and
he was he came out of the occult some of
the stuff he wrote is very
is off some of the stuff he wrote is
quite good but his one of his theories
that he has was that materialism was
like a wall
that the civilization had built around
itself to protect itself
or to isolate itself from the spiritual
world let's say
and he said it was actually in a certain
way successful like
there it's true there are less miracles
there are less manifestations you know
it's a
from the enlightenment on there less and
less connect connection
with what you would call the spiritual
world and so the materialism
philosophical materialism and then had
actually
created this wall around the world but
his theory was that
at the end one because that can't hold
at some point it's going to start to
crack
and he called it the great fissures in
the wall but he said when the wall
cracks it's going to crack at the bottom
it's going to crack
below and it's the stuff from beneath
that are going to come up
right and but people are still going to
be more isolated
from the higher beings and we've seen
like he wrote that maybe in 1920
and we've seen it you know with all the
new age insanity and all the craziness
we've seen it kind of happened manifest
itself
and so this brings me then to the
question of the you know
kind of what you're trying to bring back
which is you know the book of enoch and
the you know
the enochian traditions we could call
them have been controversial like to a
certain extent in christianity
uh but nonetheless it seems like they do
offer us a way to deal with this in the
world as we see these beings kind of
creep back into reality you know they it
offers us a
a let's say a a map or a guide to help
us understand what exactly is going on i
don't know if you've thought about that
well i think um building off what you
said
i think uh the the the rule of christ
gave
us the luxury of materialism for a while
right because because the western world
christendom
right as such right the fact that there
there weren't practicing pagans
and and so sort of idolatry
and the the religious aspects of sexual
immorality had been kind of ruled out
it kind of created this space where
there weren't a lot of demonic
manifestations and people getting
possessed and these things which were
commonplace in the ancient world
and are still commonplace in in some
parts of the world
but within christendom they became
relatively rare and that allowed
everyone to become materialists
right but the problem is that
materialism then turned on christ
himself
for a while in the 18th and 19th
centuries they kind of put brackets
around god
and christ and said well we'll get rid
of all the rest of this stuff but we'll
keep those
but once you deny those you lose that
sort of protection and that's why you
get
sort of the return of of
demonic powers of chaos sort of welling
up from the bottom like you described
and um in terms of the anakic literature
in particular
uh it was actually less controversial in
the ancient church
than it is now um
i think uh frankly sola scriptura has
poisoned the well in the west uh
where we even most orthodox people have
this very binary view
of like something is canonical and
therefore 100 percent true
and literal or
it's non-canonical and therefore it's
full of lies
and it's garbage and you shouldn't read
it and it's bad
yeah why do you think the narcic
literature was lost because
to a certain extent i think the only
copies of those texts were
kept in ethiopia and most of the whole
world had lost those traditions they
were
they kind of had faded away in some way
in the west in the west they had we we
know they were still in circulation
in the 8th and 9th centuries you have
byzantine historians drawing on that
when they write their chronicles and
write the history of the world
they're pulling directly from first
enoch for all of their
early history of the world interesting
um and
uh george uh singalos
uh in the cinquelos in the uh eighth
century
basically said this is the byzantine
word on first zenith he said it was
a apostolic apocryphon what he meant by
that was in the original meaning of
apocrypha something hidden
so he was saying this is this is a text
that has
this information that's part of the
apostolic
tradition part of the apostolic
preaching
uh saint irenaeus and his on the
apostolic preaching
basically sights straight from first
evening but
scripture states quotes from enoch like
it's but it's it's hidden in that it's
not read publicly in the churches
right because that's what canonical
means means we read it in liturgy
right it's not ready liturgy so it's
hidden in that way
but it is this apostolic tradition even
saint augustine
and i hate bashing saint gunston because
he gets picked on
way too much but saint augustine is
really the first one to really reject
oh really yeah and that's why it sort of
fell into disfavor in the west because
the west became
all about saint augustine but even he
when he talked about the book of enoch
itself
said that well yes enoch wrote something
right he says saint jude quotes it as
being from enoch
he says but this text is so old
that would mean right that means it's
it's antediluvian it's for before the
flood he says it's so old we have no way
to verify
that what we now have is the original
book of enoch
okay that's why you shouldn't trust it
right right right that was his argument
it wasn't to just say this is spurious
yeah right or it was
it was so even he who was the first one
to really be against it had this sort of
marginal acceptance and st
jerome at the same time his contemporary
went into a protracted argument about
how well noah must have had a copy on
the art
like to explain how he's going all out
my goodness like how could this survive
well noah must have had a copy that he
got from his great-grandfather
and brought with you know this whole
elaborate thing
so it was much more accepted in the
early church because they didn't have
they really had three categories they
had canonical that's read in liturgy
they had books to be read in the home
and then they had books not to be read
right or heretical and the
the the books to be read in the home so
you still find people the fifth and
sixth century quoting the shepherd of
hermas
authoritatively for example but they
wouldn't have said it was canonical they
wouldn't have read from it in liturgy
but they're still quoting from the same
thing with first enig all the way into
the
the the eighth and ninth century with
examples we still have
yeah well i'm happy to to hear that
because
i have been trying to let's say slowly
reintroduce the ideas from from uh first
enoch
mostly because it seems like it offers
us a map of what's happening around us
right now because
one of the stories of first enoch is of
course the
the increasing of technicity which is
connected with magic we try
we tend to want to separate those but
they're they're really very similar in
the sense that there's a
an accelerated modification of nature
which is brought about
by connection with these these demonic
beings and
these demonic beings teach uh you know
all the different crafts and the
different
uh also ornamentation which is important
in in in i think it's as zazel who
teaches both metallurgy and
ornamentation which is like which is
such a great great connection between
the two
uh weapon making and seduction making
you know um
but uh so but so it seems like we're
going through the same
the same situation that was happening
first enoch this acceleration
of technicity the loss of
virtue the loss of morality the falling
into sexual immorality
to an extreme degree all of this is kind
of happening at the same time
as we're talking about as we're talking
about the notion of
creating an ai for example that would be
this artificial intelligence i always
tell people if you want to know what a
fallen angel is
just imagine what ai is going to be like
that's probably going to be
the closest thing you're going to you're
going to come into contact with nai
so anyways maybe tell tell me a little
bit about your perception of that
that trope that i'm trying to bring up
here yeah i
i think i think you're right um
and uh you know one of our problems in
looking
at material from the ancient world is we
tend to assume materialism as being
what's actually true
and so when we see stuff from the
ancient world we tend to think
like like we're trying to give them a
break we'll say oh well they saw
lightning and thunder and they didn't
understand it and so therefore they had
to come up with thor
or paroon or procunus or zeus you know
and and
and then that was their explanation and
so they then they wrote stories
you know there were probably initially
metaphors and eventually people took
them as being real and then they thought
that zeus was a real being
right as an example um but but the
problem
is that number one doesn't take
seriously what these people are saying
about their own actual experiences
right and you know that they're actually
encountering divine beings
and they're engaging with them that's
what they say about themselves now we
can simply say they're all
lying if now but if we accept that idea
then we're basically saying that almost
every single text from the ancient world
is a lie that people are lying about
their their
actual lives you know across the world
consistently and interestingly they're
lying in in very similar similar ways
throughout the whole world the whole
globe right you know
uh like i'll give an example that blew
my mind when father stephen first told
me about it he said
almost every ancient culture when they
depict spiritual beings that they
encounter
depicts them as being about 15 feet tall
everywhere africa asia indo-european
cultures south america
egyptians everyone's everyone is
depicting their gods as being about 15
feet tall
like what is that about i mean i could
explain like you could explain i don't
know maybe you could explain it
right like so like you could for
instance
do the historical critical thing and say
okay well maybe someone at some ancient
indo-european point
depicted a 15-foot tall god and so then
therefore all of these indo-european
cultures got the 15-foot tall god from
that and it kind of spread out from
there
right you know essentially kind of
explain it linguistically
uh you know but the problem is you have
cultures that are not connected to those
cultures at all
that are depicting the same things
so you could either say like wow that's
an interesting massive
enormous coincidence all over the world
everywhere or you could say well maybe
they're all having a similar experience
and so they're all therefore all
depicting
the same experience that they're all
having you know
and and so like that's that's one
example of these things that are kind of
right in front of us but that we just
sort of
just disbelieve them from the outset
right
uh but but i think you're right that
that we are now experiencing
this kind of increase in um
for lack of a better term spiritual
activity right and
it's funny like i i one of the jokes
that father stephen and i have sometimes
made about
the way that we're already interacting
people with people about
uh the lord of spirits podcast is to you
know at some point we're gonna have to
say look we're not
ghostbusters you know we are we are
number one
if we are ready to believe you we are
ready to believe you
you know but but that's like that's not
what we're talking about but it's
interesting that what happens in the
ghostbusters
films right is the sense of this
increase in spiritual activity
you know they're talking about that so
that's that's interesting it's in
ghostbusters it's all materialist it's
almost yeah it's all ectoplasm
and like capturing the ghosts in these
machines it really is
like the worst of 19th century
uh kind of materialist magnetism all
that kind of
i'm sorry to say crap that came over the
19th century to kind of
to make the the spiritual world into
mater
into material categories yeah yeah
people had seances and then they would
gather this goo
which was like electro yeah
yeah that i i think the dynamic your
point which obviously is front and
center in the book of the watchers
in the book of enoch about the
connection between the increase of
kind of demonic activity and uh
the increase in technology uh has to do
with
the way even if we just stick with the
old testament
the way in the old testament that the
the spiritual powers
of of chaos and evil attack
right that their goal is the destruction
of god's creation in general and
humans in particular right and
the way they do that consistently
is by trying to give to humans
ideas thoughts wisdom
knowledge that they're not prepared for
that they aren't in a spiritual state to
receive yet
because they know that will cause
self-destruction that starts with the
serpent
with eve you know take the knowledge
yeah right yeah
that you're not prepared for yet it's
not that the tree was evil it's that
they weren't prepared yeah and all the
way through and that's the same thing in
the watchers story
right where i'm gonna give them you know
weapons technology they're not prepared
to use it responsibly
right and so they're gonna use it to
kill each other i'm going to give them
these means the women these means of
seduction
right because they're not prepared for
it and they're going to they're going to
fall into sexual immorality all these
this destruction and chaos comes yeah
and it's knowledge that fills your
desire this knowledge to fulfill your
desire for power
for domination for seduction all of
these things that
it's basically how to act upon the world
to get what you want
is what they're giving the people yeah
and and that's
that experience again like father andrew
was saying is universal that's why
you read about prometheus
that's why it's it's it's all of that
understanding that there are these
spiritual powers
who gave to man knowledge he wasn't
ready for that's been destructive and
they were punished for it
is is uh universal
yeah around the world and you see it
it's funny because you
even today i don't know because i i've
i've mentioned this
before i've been sadly i mean strangely
you've been connected with all these
people doing
doing uh psychedelics and so you know
they talk about these mechanical elves
that they meet whatever they call them
cockrells or whatever machine elves
machine elves are i don't know um and i
keep
and i i read a story a comic book story
about santa claus which was written by a
weird pagan guy
uh grant with a grant morrison wrote a
santa claus story
and uh and he has santa claus meeting
these machine
ls right he takes some some mushrooms or
whatever
then he sees these elves and then he he
makes toys better
but then he also like ends up making his
sleigh into like a super sleigh or
whatever
but what i was thinking is that wow
they're actually encountering the demons
from first enoch like
they're they're they're actually
encountering these beings that are
giving them like mechanical formula
or they're giving them showing them uh
technological feats
that they that they then kind of
encounter and so it's just very strange
because we already have this story from
the stories from thousands and thousands
of years ago
but we seem to be going through similar
process right now
yeah and and ayahuasca isn't a new thing
right like it's better to give you an
idea of how long it's been around
the greek word that's usually when you
read sorcery in your english bible
the greek word that's usually behind
that is pharmaca yeah
because they were using pharmaceutical
right even the oracle adelphi
was inhaling fumes coming out of a a
crack in the ground to produce an
altered state of consciousness in order
to be possessed by
the spirit of apollo you know and and
give these oracles so
yeah it's not a new thing that
experience has just continued into the
modern world
and you know one of the things i think
that makes so much of this stuff
very urgent is that like
we were just talking about drug use for
instance right
for a lot of people they might ask like
why why is it immoral for me to do
psychedelic drugs right and i mean if
you listen to everything we just said
then it becomes clear why it's a super
bad idea why it's
a rebellion against god because you're
entering into communion with these other
spirits
it's dangerous it's like it's like going
on down a dark road without anybody to
guide you and
you know you encounter beings and you
think they're there to help you like
what are you talking what are you doing
this is really not
safe yeah and it's and you know what's
what's interesting like if you
understand christian morality not just
in terms of a list of things you're
supposed to do and not supposed to do
but but rather actually like this is the
right way to interact with the
with the spiritual world as it as it
actually exists
then all the other elements for instance
of christian morality such as sexual
morality
and even things like like the right way
to worship god like this all makes much
more sense if we understand it as not
just being instead of arbitrary tastes
or preferences or or even just desires
but this is
actually you're interacting with reality
and there are things that result from
that interaction
right so like that's why for instance
over and over again in scripture you've
got idolatry and sexual immorality are
just
paired together as always going together
you know as as an example and and i i
think it's it's it's
you know it's it's frustrating on the
one hand to see the modern world just
diving headlong into immorality
not because it's like we're sitting here
and saying look how moral we are
how dare they you know like that's not
but but the problem is a lot of people
that's how they see what christianity is
that's
what they think christianity is a sort
of moralism but but really it's like
it's like
that that immorality is immoral not
because it violates
a law somewhere in the sense of a a
legal code
but but rather that it is you know it's
like
telling your children not to stick their
hand on a hot stove like that's
reality like it's not just right and
wrong don't tell me what's don't tell me
what to do
dad you know like no it's like no you
are going to be burned if you engage in
immorality you are entering into
communion with demons
you are you know that that's just an
objective truth
and you can watch people like i saw this
as a pastor watch people who
who get into the get into it a little
bit and then get it to a little bit more
and get it to a little bit more and then
you know they would not even recognize
where they had gone
you know when they got it where they
were at the beginning of that process
um and so this to me this is i'm
i could just say that i'm very excited
to see where this is going to go
and i'm really i'm really happy to to
that you're taking this trip and in a
way i'm happy that you're doing it then
i'm not doing it because
first of all i don't have the knowledge
to do it of course but also because i
know
this road is going to be fraught with
all kinds of strangeness
that is going to manifest itself to you
in terms of
in terms of demonic things uh attacking
you
but also people coming to you like like
father uh
father andrew already said coming for
help trying to get them to
to deal with these experiences that
they've had that they don't understand
in a modern world where
you know all of this has been although
we although it's everywhere in our
fiction it's everywhere in our stories
you know in the real world people try to
avoid it or try not to talk about it
or put it to the side um but nonetheless
it's
the if you look at all the card readers
and all the new age stuff and
people are trying to understand this and
so
and so i'm happy to see that that i've
got orthodox priests
trying to guide people along the road so
they don't get lost i
i think that you know and and i say this
not in a kind of
um to draw attention to us kind of way
but
but i think the fact that we are priests
um it's not just a question of like
authority right in the sense of like
although it is we're talking about
principalities right so
so that's the kind of authority yeah
right that's the authority that i mean
is you know and it's interesting like
for instance i've i had the experience
one time
just and this was this happened years
ago where my wife was somewhere
and i mean i wasn't even present but my
wife was somewhere and this woman
approached her
uh in public and essentially kind of
offered her
um i don't know if it was a seance or a
fortune telling or something like that
like
you know and my wife told me that she
looked the woman straight in the eye and
said my husband is an orthodox priest
that was the one thing she said and she
said that the woman like drew back
in sort of shock right right
so it's it's like it's it's not that
it's not that like i'm some holy person
i'm not
i'm not but but as as priests our task
is to stand at the altar
and to to um facilitate people communing
directly with god and being
engaged with the angels and the saints
and so
you know there are many times you see in
scripture where priests engage
in this kind of spiritual warfare not
again not because they have some special
holiness all their own but because this
is the way that god has chosen to
to work right you know that offering
incense that offering up the eucharist
these things
are spiritually powerful and and not
just in an individual way that
makes somebody have a spiritual
experience but but
like you know for instance that offering
up incense
fumigates the space
from dark powers like that's literally
what is happening when incense is being
it's clearing them out
you know and you see it happening in the
bible right it happens
you know father stephen what was that
what's that passage where you see
is it aaron and a couple of other ones
like there's some kind of plague that
has happened with the people of israel
and so they offer up incense
to to drive this out after after the
rebellion of korra
uh aaron takes his sensor and his sons
take their sensors and sort of stand
betw
the languages that they stand between
the living and the dead
um offering offering incense
and as they stand there sort of the
plague stops at that line
like that that forms the the sort of
barrier between between life and death
and yeah that
that's and this is another one of those
things that ancient people just
understood
you see people offering incense and
incense is offered as a sacrifice
there are altars of incense right um
but it says is offered all over all over
the world in every culture
and it's so ingrained that
uh the the greek word for purification
right catharsia right is derived from
the acadian word for incense
kataru that's where it comes from
um and there's something i think the
materialists who are watching this who
are listening to this
they really struggle to to understand
this stuff
and i always want to try to point them
back to
the notion of intelligence and the
notion of consciousness that
that we brought up at the beginning
which is that if
the world is constituted by
consciousnesses or by intelligences that
if these
intelligent patterns are the way in
which the world lays itself out
then it's not strange to think that
ritual behavior
or that acting in a way
that is meaningful will will be part of
it will alleviate these problems that
that doing certain things that have
meaning and that have that have a
coherent kind of symbolic
uh ritual meaning will affect the world
because that's how the world lays itself
out all as
meaning and as intelligence is um of
course if people can't
even concede that or understand that
then then it all looks like superstition
and bunk and just whatever
um but we do it all the time we use
meaning to
to affect the world all the time you
know and the most recent one is
one of them the most real ones is this
mask wearing thing
so so much of the mask wearing thing is
a ritual behavior
i even saw someone posted recently a a
post from the new england journal of
medicine
saying that the the main aspect of mask
wearing is a talisman
function where as people wear the mask
they feel safe and they they are willing
to act out in the world because
they have this kind of protective
garment that is shielding them from
from their perceived danger you know and
so that's and that's a that's a ritual
that's a ritual behavior
yeah i mean it's it's i think again just
basic
that that ritual well ritual does
something
right too often people look at ritual
they
obviously 99.999 percent of people in
the world have never studied ritual
theory
but um but we look at ritual we tend to
look at it in this sort of diagnostic
way where
even if we're talking about the liturgy
or the parts of the liturgy
right well this represents this and this
represents that and this stands for that
but what
ritual does something and
so yes the person who participates in
ritual is going to be shaped by that
the community that participates in
ritual is going to be shaped by that
they're going to be brought together as
a community
that community is going to be formed in
certain ways and the example i use with
people who are just raw materialists is
i talk to them about sports
maybe this only works in the u.s i don't
know maybe it works with
with football other places like
non-american football but
but that right it does not matter what
socks you wear
in terms of whether your team will win
or not it doesn't matter whether you
watch the game like on a materialist
level
yeah it doesn't matter what you do it's
not going to affect the outcome of the
game
but you cannot tell a sports fan that
what they do
and their rituals and those kind of
things you know dressing up like a team
member
yeah you're right yeah just look like a
team
as far as they're concerned that's part
of the game that's part of their team
winning
is is their support from their house
miles and miles away you know so
we understand it at some base level even
if we won't let ourselves
fully sort of appropriate it that the
example i always use is shaking
hands because you know you could say
shaking hand
represents showing your hands that you
don't have a weapon that
shaking hands represents you know a
movement towards the other blah blah
blah but it doesn't just represent it it
you're actually doing
the thing you're encountering someone
and the gesture
is creating the bond between you and
that person it's not just they
represent although you can you can find
all the meaning
and it's there you can you can show you
can show how all of this
is very very meaningful but it's also
acting in the world and
transforming the world in the way that
that ritual does
yeah yeah well this has been
we've been going for way longer than i
usually go i knew this was gonna happen
but uh but i i am really excited like i
said and i
and i first of all appreciate uh you
coming on here and i want to tell all
the people listening to
tune in there's it'll it'll probably be
a lot to think about a lot to discuss
a lot to debate about i'm certain you
you're going to create all kinds of
controversy with this podcast
uh which is going to be good controversy
that'll bring up
the bring up help us understand a lot of
the
the spiritual malaise that is in the
modern world today so thank you for
for your time and thank you for all your
efforts but it's really hard because
it's so
huge i mean i mean you you can talk
about that you'll be able to talk about
this for seasons
and seasons of this podcast years i
think i think there's years with the
podcasting here
we we started out with uh monotheism is
bunk
so it could be
yeah more from here i totally agree i
made a video like was it two years ago
called the problem with monotheism
um and especially for the modern
atheists it's such a
such a great thing to understand you
know
when someone you know you this argument
you've seen it probably online where
they say
you know i'm you're an atheist too i
just believe in one less god than you do
right like you know what you've got the
wrong guy because i believe in all the
gods
that's right yeah oh yeah yeah that's it
and it's you know we only brushed on it
in the first the first podcast
but you go and take any old testament
course
at a university in the united states i'm
sure this is doubly true
in like canada and europe and you know
and they're going to tell you
that israel started out polytheistic
like everyone else and then they evolved
they do monolatry and then they evolved
into
you know unitarian monotheism sometime
around the time of
of christ and then they watch around the
time of christ is when they they go that
far really
oh yeah yeah they have it all laid out
and it's they've just adopted wholesale
this 19th century german thing that yeah
yeah yeah the hegelian thing
because then what they want to do is
they want to say okay so monotheism is
the thesis
or no polytheism is the thesis
monotheism is the antithesis
and the trinity is the synthesis oh
right okay that's the thing right they
want to do that whole hegelian move
you know look at rabbinical judaism they
have
all the weird stuff like they have way
more weird stuff than we do
oh yeah that there are there are some
key books that i recommend to people all
the time
by orthodox jewish scholars talking
about second temple judaism
and the fact that they were not
unitarian monotheists that they were at
least
bynatarian sometimes more in fact
benjamin summer who's a professor at
jewish theological seminary in the us
who wrote one of those books in a talk
said that trinitarianism is tame
compared to a lot of forms of judaism
because he was talking about different
forms of kabbalah that have like a
hundred
yeah like a hundred persons of the
godhead
yeah well if you even the the the famous
sephiroth
tree like they have ten manifest ten ten
let's say
manifestations of god and it's all god
like the whole truth is god
and so it's like wait so what's your
problem with the trinity already yeah
yeah and so he he just comes out and
says you know this is
this is but this is i like sending
people to the jewish sources on it
yes then they can't say i'm trying to
pull something right i'm like no these
these are orthodox jews they don't have
a dog in the fight
right like they're
all right it was great to talk to both
of you and uh and i'll i'll send you a
link as soon as this is posted i might
even try to post it today or maybe
tomorrow morning
thank you jonathan we appreciate it yes
thank you for having us
and so and maybe in a in a few months
once you've you've given us a full
demonology and angiology
i'll have you back on the on the on the
show and we can we can talk about it
again
sounds good all right absolutely bye-bye
hope you enjoyed my discussion with
father andrew and father stephen make
sure you check out
the lord of spirits podcast on ancient
faith
i'll be of course putting links to that
in the show description
also make sure you check out father
andrews other podcast called the ammon
sewell podcast one of his many podcasts
actually
um i was on there just a few weeks ago
talking about dragons that was also a
lot of fun
and don't forget that the symbolic world
also has a clips channel
where lisa parrot is putting together
clips
of all my videos organizing them in
subject and so
if you've ever wanted to know what i
think of this or that it is probably the
best place to check that out
and don't forget of course with all the
strange youtube changes that are going
on
don't forget to make sure you are
subscribed to the channel if you want to
get notifications for the next video and
of course everything i'm doing
is done thanks to your help and your
support so go check out the
symbolicworld.com
support if you want to help out the
podcast so thanks everybody and i'll
talk to you very
[Music]
soon